hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the apple polishing cloth the
weird thing is everyone's making fun of
it but
it's weirdly out of stock everywhere and
if you order it now you're not going to
get it until january 15th of next year
must mean that somebody bought them me i
did and a lot of people did on twitter
some of them may have bought them as
jokes but
you guys when i went through and bought
my macbook and i saw this polishing
cloth as like an add-on i did not even
think twice about it because i have one
of these polishing cloths i'm not sure
if it's the same exact one but i got two
of them that came with my pro display
xdrs and it is by far the nicest
microfiber cloth that i have ever used
obviously because it came with two very
very expensive monitors and i was so
impressed with the quality of it
initially when i first got it i was like
this is the best cloth in the world i
want to buy another one so i went on
apple's website to buy another polishing
cloth and this was like maybe a year ago
and i couldn't find it anywhere so when
i saw this pop up as an add-on to my
macbook pro i didn't even think twice
about it i was like oh cool i'm glad
they're finally selling it and then i
hop on twitter and saw it was like a
meme and people were making fun of it
and i was like
make fun of it all you want i am
incredibly hyped up about this polishing
cloth and i know what you're going to
say oh just seeing you're a sheep you're
wasting your money you know what this is
something that i want to spend it on do
with that what you will let's unbox this
polishing cloth let's see if there's
anything on the back well it has
polishing cloth written in several
different uh languages here safe for use
on all apple displays including nano
texture glass which is good to know
because i do have banana texture on
those pro display xdr so you do have to
be very careful when you are cleaning
these types of things because you don't
want to be using anything that can
actually damage it so approved for use
on the pro display xtrs with nanoglass
so much like most apple products it's
got a little pull tab here so we're
going to
pull the tab
it's the same one
oh i'm so happy
yeah
this is exciting safe for use on all
apple displays and surfaces for
infrequent cleaning and hard to remove
smudges on nano texture glass a seventy
percent alcohol solution may be used
that's actually good to know because i
didn't know i could actually use that on
the display so all right so here it is
it's
it's a piece of
cloth but it's a very nice premium piece
of cloth this cloth
is very
very nice and of course it has an apple
logo on it i know what you're going to
say oh of course it has an apple logo on
it you'll buy anything with an apple
logo on it
[Music]
well you're not wrong should i clean
something with it that's probably a good
idea look at this do you want to see can
we get some smudge action can you even
tell if that's smudgy look at that you
see that smudge
look at that no more smudge i know what
you're gonna say any random microfiber
cloth would be able to do the same thing
i mean you're not wrong but this is such
a nice soft feel and it has an apple
logo on it and it was dollars and it's
worth every penny of it all
two thousand and eighteen pennies of it
i was joking that i was gonna do an
unboxing of this and honestly i didn't
even think that it was something that
would be worthwhile but i just wanted to
show you that i bought this and i'm
freaking proud of it i will wear this as
a badge of honor i would buy some more
of them and make a full outfit of it but
unfortunately they're all sold out and
do you know why
because this is premium quality if i've
ever seen it and i'm sure now you're
probably gonna want one as well
well you can get one next year let's see
the exact date of when this is available
i know you guys think i'm crazy but this
is the only thing that i really have
ever used on my pro display xtr's and
when you're trying to clean something
that is seven thousand dollars you want
it to be premium quality you don't want
to be scrubbing that thing with some
random cloth that's gonna leave dust all
over the place and that's what i liked
about this one completely honest this is
incredibly sincere and genuine i'm not
making this up because i've been using
one of these for the past couple of
years now and i thought it was so
incredible i wanted to buy another one
and now that the opportunity is here
i have done so 20
delivers january 11th through january
25th that leads me to believe that a lot
of you
also bought yourselves a polishing cloth
as well whether it was for serious or
for joke you're going to get this thing
and you're going to be like wow you're
right it's very nice since we're here
and i'm already making a video i got my
air pods in these are the new airpods
three
and for my airpods i got them actually
customized so i want to check these out
the ones that i had before obviously
were a review unit and these ones are my
very own customize them with my name
and some emojis i forget what emojis i
got i think there was a skull
maybe a pig
oh my gosh the font size is so big it
used to be a very tiny fin font i think
i prefer the small tiny thin font better
this is very aggressive the emojis are
very big as well so i did skull and a
little pig
yeah so here they are so i have been
using the airpods 3 for the past couple
of days weeks i don't even know i've
lost track i think it's been like a week
and a half at this point the fit is very
different i know a lot of you guys have
probably received yours already or
you're thinking about it and i would say
if you have tried the airpods pro and
you've kind of had some struggles with
those these are kind of a very similar
size to those and if the
small original version of the air pods
work perfect for your ears there's a
good chance these will work and
sometimes they don't and it's really
difficult because a lot of these
headphones which are kind of like the
one size fits all that's just impossible
the way that my ear shape is they're
very picky about the types of headphones
that i can put in but for whatever
reason those original pair of air pods
are by far the best fit for my ears ever
the
sound quality though on this
gen 3 is so impressive it is almost on
par with the airpods pro now if you do
get these you're going to be missing out
on like the transparency mode and the
noise cancellation but the thing that i
do like a lot about the newer ones is
the fact that the case and the earbuds
are water resistant to an ipx for rating
and i think that's actually awesome
because i'm not gonna lie to you i think
all this time i thought my case was more
water resistant than it was i have put
those things through a lot so i just
kind of assumed oh yeah yeah it's gonna
be perfectly fine i've never had any
issues with it now just kind of thinking
back to all of the running and all of
the traveling i used to run in the rain
all the time and have my air pods in my
pocket and they've definitely got some
exposure to water and now these ones i
know for a fact are way more weather
resistant that kind of gives me a much
better peace of mind when i'm traveling
or running or working out or doing
anything but either way it has been such
a crazy tech season this october there's
been so many videos that i've wanted to
make and i honestly have just run out of
time i've been in the process of moving
my studio i've been visiting my family
and also just so much has been going on
in my personal life that it is
absolutely overwhelming trying to get
all this content out for you guys so i'm
just super grateful for you guys who are
always checking in seeing how i'm doing
and also coming back here to my youtube
channel and always being so supportive
in the comments so you guys are awesome
and i do have a bunch more videos
planned i'm also currently planning to
do kind of like some follow-up videos on
the apple watch the macbook and then
even the iphone because it's been almost
like a month and a half at this point
that the new iphone has come out i feel
like the time has flown by so quickly
and before you know it it is gonna be
next year and you'll be able to get
yourself your very own polishing cloth
anyway if you guys are new here hi i'm
justine i'm sure you have heard of the
apple obsessed fan girl you can call me
whatever you want but i do cover a lot
of other tech here not just specific to
apple so if you guys enjoy that type of
content give this video a thumbs up be
sure to subscribe so you can see any
other videos that i post hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post new
videos and with that my friends i'll see
you in the next one bye be so funny if i
wasn't recording be like hilarious i
would laugh so hard be so funny